hi there Internet I'm John Oliver host
of last week tonight's now we are off at
the moment but as it's holiday season I
really like to talk to you about
something that may be about to happen
where you live and that is SantaCon it's
the the manufactured events that I
believe is short for Santa Condoleezza
Rice she she deserves a better legacy
than that not a lot better to be honest
but slightly better now if you do not
know what Santa con is first of all
congratulations but I'm afraid that your
innocence is about to be shattered
Santa con is essentially a day long pub
crawl organized in various cities where
thousands of people can dress up a Santa
and get hammered
now however fun and whimsical it may
sound it isn't it is not that just
listen to this man and bear in mind he's
talking about Santa's here they are very
crazy ridiculously drink and they get
drunk on the new beer DBF terrible too
much alcohol is Linda fights and a lot
of complaints about crude and lewd
behavior yeah
that is what Santa con is it's not a
magical occasion it's a terrifying
combination of binge drinking public
urination and trauma to small children
that decades of therapy will never
manage to reverse here is how bad it is
last year there were 14 people arrested
and 4 officers injured during SantaCon
in Hoboken New Jersey alone just think
about that arrested doing SantaCon in
Hoboken New Jersey
that might be literally the saddest
sentence in existence
is way worse than for sale baby shoes
never worn because at least that baby
was just dead and not arrested in a
Santa outfit in a repeat Hoboken New
Jersey and you need to know it's not
just violence I he was in greenery on
14th and third aisle for I'll never
forget I saw an explicit sex act in the
island - Santa's going at it
I'm truly sorry that you saw that and
look not to victim blame here but you
were in oil for the most erotic of the
duane reade arts that's canned goods and
baby care powders and chowder's and an
exotic palace devoted to the
pleasures of the flesh everybody knows
that I'll fall for life son now now now
I should mention SantaCon does have a
bright side in that many local Santa
cones donate to charity in New York City
participants can even buy a ticket that
is tax-deductible which might be
literally the most humiliating tax
deduction after a contribution to the
Church of Scientology well where's
Shelly David where is she where's Shelly
and look look nearly any charitable
donation is good but I will point out
according to the website for New York's
SantaCon the amount they've raised over
the past nine years is four hundred
fifty thousand dollars which sounds like
a lot yes until you realize that works
out to around fifty thousand dollars a
year from an event that reportedly
attracts around 30,000 participants
meaning if you do some rough math
they're raising just over a dollar sixty
per person which is about as much as you
could raise just by collecting the spare
change that falls out of the pockets of
all the Santa's each other in
the middle of Duane reaps this
happens this this year is actually the
21st anniversary of New York SantaCon
ironically it's technically old enough
to drink now and and I would argue that
this SantaCon should probably be the
last because the magic of Christmas
should simply not include having to
watch Santa finger blasting and elf in a
Wells Fargo ATM vestibule at 10:45 a.m.
and I'm not alone here even the people
who started SantaCon are now sick of it
in 2014 some of the original organizers
staged a funeral for Santa con at the
same time as the event it is time to put
an end to this madness that is about to
befall us or to or to put it in another
perhaps more Christmasy way boom twas
the night before Santa con and all
through the city the bars were preparing
for Santa's who are shitty the children
were nestled as though nothing was wrong
not knowing tomorrow they'd see santa's
dong when what to my wondering eyes
should appear but the actual Santa
without any beer he gave me a look and
pulled out two stocking to wipe tears
from his eyes and then said something
shocking
he said I'm not usually the judgmental
type after all what do you think I
smoked in this point but as sure as I am
that my red sleigh flies this should be
the year that SantaCon dies Santa then
left disappeared in the sky with his
sleigh full of presents and a gleam in
his eye but I heard him exclaim ere he
drove out of sight hohoho
Santa can to all and to all a good
night
listen to him goodbye Santa you heard
the man thank you so much for watching
we are back next February happy holidays
you
[Music]